Moin. Was macht das Mikrofon wieder für Dinger? Da stimmt doch wieder was nicht hier.
Das hat doch wieder an meiner Mikrofon-Lautstärke rumgestellt hier. Ich sehe das sofort. Was ist das?
Windows. Alter. Wo stellt man den Shit überhaupt jetzt ein?
Das hat sowas von an meiner Audio-Lautstärke. Ja, ja, ich... Ey.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist? Diese neue...
Was hab ich denn normal? Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich normal eingestellt hab.
78 oder sowas, hä?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass es nicht angeht, wenn ich einatme. Einfach nur.
68 vielleicht? Ja, besser.
Chat, ich hab echt... Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt so passt.
69, ja. Was hab ich normalerweise?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich normalerweise... Ist das jetzt normale Lautstärke?
Oder?
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, was ich normal hab, weil ich stell da dran normalerweise nicht rum.
Neo-Wim in der Helix probier ich nicht aus. Wenn schon Neo-Wim.
Oder Nio-Wim, wie es die geilen Leute sagen, ja.
Oder hab ich doch 80? Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht, Leute.
Ich hätt auf jeden Fall nicht 100.
Ja, so in dem Dreh. Irgendwas um 70 werd ich haben. Keine Ahnung.
Und wisst ihr auch, warum?
Wisst ihr, warum das so scheiße ist, die Einstellung? Warum die so verkackt ist hier wieder in Windows?
Weil unter Windows jedes dahergelaufene Konferenzprogramm, Tool, was auch immer, der Meinung ist, an den Audio-Settings rumstellen zu müssen.
Warum? Weil die meisten User zu dumm sind, irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise ihre Audio-Geräte ordentlich einzustellen.
So. Und bei mir verstellt es das immer, weil es natürlich auch denkt, dass ich meine Audio-Geräte falsch eingestellt hab.
Ich muss ja grad eine Schulung machen und die geht, wer hätte das gedacht, über WebEx.
Chatkill, wer von euch hatte schon mal die große Ehre, was mit WebEx machen zu dürfen?
WebEx und Cisco, oder wie meinte ich noch? Cisco. Cisco WebEx.
Die Schulung findet über WebEx statt. Jawoll.
Hab ich ja auch hier irgendwo WebEx. Ja, man findet's. Ne, man findet's nicht.
Was auch immer. Ich muss so eine komische App installieren.
Das ist richtig reudig, Leute. WebEx. Richtig schlimm.
Kommt's dir vor wie 1998?
Da war, wir hatten früher, also wirklich früher, als wir die Ausbildung gemacht haben, hatten wir eine Videokonferenzanlage von Tandberg.
Die wurden dann auch irgendwann von Cisco gekauft.
Und die Experience war legit besser als heute. WebEx, ey.
WebXD, XD, XD.
WebXD müsste das heißen.
Warum wird denn hier Cuemo so krass geupdatet?
WebEx, Alter.
Und die Schulung wieder, ne? Leute.
Die Schulung wieder. Die Leute, Alter.
Die Leute, Alter.
Erster Tag.
Bei gefühlter Hälfte, okay, nicht ganz der Hälfte, bei einem Drittel.
Geht erst mal Audio nicht.
Danach geht Audio bei manchen, weil sie sich übers Telefon eingewählt haben.
Übers Telefon eingewählt.
Ich betone das nochmal.
Über Telefon eingewählt.
Nicht etwa, dass die irgendwie die App oder so gestartet haben auf dem Handy.
Nein, nein.
Die haben eine Telefonnummer angerufen, damit man teilnehmen kann an der, an der, dass da das Audiosound übertragen wird.
Die haben sich mit dem Telefon eingewählt.
Über, über normales Telefon mit Rufnummer anrufen, ja.
Am 20. hingekriegt.
Audio-Qualität ist Todes teilweise bei den Leuten am Start.
Aber man ist das ja gewöhnt, ja.
Sobald irgendwie online-mäßig was läuft und da nicht einfach nur normale IT-Leute am Start sind,
also die übelsten, die, die, die, so Leute wie wir halt, ja, so No-Life-Keller-Sitzer,
dann weißt du gleich, Audio geht erst mal die erste halbe Stunde nicht richtig.
Ja, ist echt so.
Ja.
Und die Leute.
Ohne Mist, Leute.
Die sind so langsam alle.
Man, die Schulung ist schon echt sehr langweilig, ja.
Und die Übungen, die man da macht, die sind eigentlich so typisch Microsoft-Style.
Kennt ihr die alten Microsoft-Style-Schulungen?
Wir haben eine offizielle PowerPoint-Präsentation, die muss abgearbeitet werden.
Wir lesen die, die Trainer lesen im Prinzip nur offizielle PowerPoint-Präsentationen vor,
die nur nicht mal von ihnen erstellt wurden.
Und dann musst du...
Bei Übungen im Prinzip dir einen PDF nehmen
und einfach wirklich Buchstabe für Buchstabe abtippen,
damit es am Ende auch funktioniert und die nächste Übung, die darauf aufbaut, klappt.
So, so ist das gemacht.
Das hat nichts, gar nichts mit Verstehen zu tun.
Schon gar nicht...
Ich meine, gut, ich bin ganz froh, weil die Software ist wirklich Schrott.
Also, wenn ich...
Ich krieg da schon Anfälle, wenn ich in dem Webinterface rumklickern muss,
was aussieht wie aus fünf verschiedenen Zeitepochen.
Aber gut, das haben sie sich vor Windows abgeguckt.
Windows hat nicht nur fünf unterschiedliche Zeitepochen.
Windows hat...
15 verschiedene Zeitepochen.
Da gibt's doch diesen Screenshot.
Äh, warte mal.
Das ist ein Screenshot.
Windows Designs Screenshot.
Gibt's doch da.
Different Windows Designs Screenshots.
Ja, keck.
Ja, das hier meine ich.
Dankeschön, Reddit.
Beste.
Das ist aber immer noch die volle Auflösung, oder?
Sag mal, Reddit macht auch mittlerweile einen Wettbewerb.
Wie mach ich die Webseite besonders schrottig, oder?
Darf ich's jetzt...
Oh, jetzt darf ich's aufmachen.
Ja, ist...
Dankeschön.
Super, super, Reddit.
Ja?
Also, ich meine, die gucken sich das von Microsoft ab.
Microsoft hat auch...
Übrigens, da ist halt immer alles dabei.
Hier ist nicht mal alles dabei.
Wisst ihr, was hier fehlt?
Mein Lieblingsmenü, was ich euch schon hunderttausendmal gezeigt hab.
Mein Lieblingsmenü mit Windows 3.11-Icon.
Mit Windows 3.11-Icons.
Gibt noch mehr so richtig hübsche...
Noch mehr so mega hübsche Icons, ja.
Was?
Chat, Chat.
Was soll es überhaupt sein?
Ich erkenne nicht mal, was ist das überhaupt?
Die Auflösung ist so niedrig, ich weiß gar nicht, was das sein soll.
Ich kann das wirklich legit nicht erkennen.
Das fehlt noch.
Ja, und so ungefähr wie die Windows-Design...
Hier unter Windows durcheinander gewurschtelt sind.
Ungefähr so sieht das Webinterface aus.
Hat es auch aus fünf unterschiedlichen Zeitepochen zusammen gewurschtelt.
Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte...
Ey, die Leute sind so langsam.
Ich weiß nicht, ich checke auch nicht alles, ja.
Ich habe auch schon mal Mist geklickt, weil man diese Anleitung wortwörtlich durchmachen muss, ja.
Aber ich konnte es bisher immer alleine fixen.
Die Leute sind so langsam.
Die Schulung geht vier Tage.
Also ging jetzt am Dienstag los.
Dienstag, 9 bis 17 Uhr.
9 bis 17 Uhr.
Gut, glücklicherweise bin ich mit den Übungen immer schon durch.
Ich kann dann 16 oder 16.30 Uhr, wenn die fertig sind, haue ich die mal gleich ab.
Aber müsst ihr euch vorstellen?
Es geht vier Tage, 9 bis 17 Uhr.
Man hat insgesamt ungefähr ein PDF mit so ungefähr, weiß nicht, 400 Seiten oder so.
Und das sind die typischen Oldschool-Microsoft-Anleitungen.
Es ist keine Microsoft.
Es ist keine Microsoft-Schulung, by the way, ja.
Aber es sind so die typischen Microsoft-Style-Anleitungen, die du so ganz genau wortwörtlich abtippen musst, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Und du kannst im Prinzip 90% skippen.
Du musst eigentlich gar nichts lesen.
Du musst immer nur die einzelnen Punkte durchgehen, dann hast du es.
Easy.
Es ist wirklich super easy.
Und gestern sollten wir machen bis Seite 105 ungefähr.
Im Prinzip sind es, selbst wenn du 40 Seiten Übungen machst, sind das im Prinzip maximal eine halbe Stunde.
Ein bisschen rumgeklicken.
Das ist super easy.
Gestern Abend bin ich abgehauen, bin eine Runde rennen gegangen.
Dann habe ich die Übung schnell fertig gemacht, irgendwie 45 Minuten.
Und heute Mittag, als wir irgendwie auf Seite 141 oder so waren, haben dann Leute gesagt, ich hätte da nochmal eine Frage zu Seite 101.
Wo ich mir dann gedacht habe, Alter, wie kann man so langsam sein?
Das ist einfach dreimal.
Wenn ich da geklicke, dann sind 10 Seiten fertig.
Das ist wirklich durchschnittliche Schulungs-Experience.
Schlimm.
Habe ich eigentlich schon rebooted?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich trinke ja schon was, ist ja gut.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Aber schlimm, ey.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock, das noch zwei Tage weiter zu machen.
Es ist so langweilig, Leute.
Es ist so langweilig.
Ich lese zwischendurch Teams und gucke in meine E-Mails rein und schreibe sogar.
Manchmal auf irgendwas noch eine Antwort.
Es ist so langweilig.
Die machen das gewissen.
Es kann schon sein.
Es gibt zwar Möglichkeiten.
Entweder machen die es gewissenhaft oder sind einfach nur lahm.
Gibt es da keine Chat-GPT-Plugins?
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber du musst ja dort in so einem Übungs-Lab.
Du hast, glaube ich, insgesamt so, was weiß ich, so 8 VMs.
Und auf denen musst du halt was klicken und machen.
Und das wird schwierig über Chat-GPT.
Reboot.
Ich müsste das mal aliasen.
Immer mit einer random Anzahl verschieden viel R's.
Mal ist es Reboot, mal ist es Reboot.
Ja.
Genau, Max.
So sieht es aus.
Sonst, sonst noch alles normal im Kopf.
Aber es ist wirklich langweilig.
Gibt es denn wenigstens ein schönes Zertifikat am Ende?
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Könnte man aber machen danach.
Mache ich aber nicht.
Leute, der einzige Grund, warum ich diese Schulung mache, ist,
weil der Herr hat mir gesagt, dass ich das nicht mache.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht.
Pass mal auf, das ist wirklich die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken, was der hat.
Der Hersteller hat in seinen Lizenzbedingungen stehen,
ey, Leute, die die Software von uns gekauft haben,
damit eure Mitarbeiter die Software benutzen dürfen,
beziehungsweise sich daran anmelden dürfen und sich einloggen dürfen,
müssen die eine Schulung bei uns gemacht haben.
Das ist wirklich, das ist legit die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken für die.
Überlegt euch mal.
Normalerweise verkaufst du eine Software, verkaufst vielleicht noch Support,
verkaufst noch eine Software für die Werkstatt,
Vielleicht sogar Jahreslizenzen oder sowas.
Und dann musst du noch jeden neuen Mitarbeiter, der auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie damit was zu tun hat,
und das sind bei uns dann schon immer recht viele, in eine über 5000 Euro teure Schulung schicken.
Die haben ohne Schiss, die haben die Lizenz zum Geldtrucken erfunden mit den Lizenzbedingungen.
Das muss ich mir auch merken. Ich brauche auch irgendwas, was Pflicht ist, aber wo die Leute das nur bei mir machen können.
So nach dem Motto, wie du willst das machen, ja dann musst du bei mir jetzt hier mindestens 5000 Euro bezahlen, dass du das machen darfst.
Also was ich gespielt habe, kurz bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe, ist tatsächlich, ich habe noch eine Runde Black Mesa gespielt, mal wieder, Half-Life.
Das willst du aber wahrscheinlich nicht hören, weil das ist ein Game von 1998 und das Remake ist ja auch schon über 10 Jahre alt.
Ansonsten, was spiele ich denn aktuell gerade? Lass mich mal überlegen.
Ich habe Wisions of Mana gespielt, weil ich Secret of Mana Fanboy bin. Das ist gar nicht so übel, wenn ich auch lieber 2D Pixel Grafik hätte.
Ansonsten, was spiele ich denn?
Ich habe ganz viel Zeug gekauft in letzter Zeit auf Steam.
Was wir machen, ja ich habe mich nur gerade darüber aufgeregt, dass meine Schulung, die ich gerade machen muss, so langweilig ist.
Und ein bisschen abgelästert über die Leute, die so lahm sind.
Delta Force, Delta Force kenne ich. Delta Force hat mich abgeschreckt mit Bots in den, nicht als Spieler getarnte Bots in den Matches.
Welche Schulung? Ich sage nicht, welche Software, aber es ist, falls du mal eine Schulung früher von Microsoft gemacht hast, machen musstest, es ist so ähnlich.
Im Prinzip ist es eine Wiederholung von offiziellen PowerPoint Slides und ein 450-seitiges PDF,
was man wirklich nicht mehr sieht.
Was man wirklich wortwörtlich eintippen muss, sonst funktionieren die Übungen nicht.
Also im Lernen ist da echt Fehlanzeige, aber ist egal.
Ich mache das ja nicht, damit ich es was, ich mache das ja nicht, dass ich wirklich was, was großartig da am Ende kann.
Es wäre natürlich schön, wenn das der Fall wäre, aber ich bezweifle es bei solcher Art von Schulung.
Es ist hauptsächlich so, dass in den Lizenzbedingungen des Herstellers steht, die Leute, die sich dort einloggen, die die Software benutzen, die müssen eine offizielle Schulung von denen besucht haben, damit sie das überhaupt durchführen können.
Das ist, wie gesagt, das ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken für die.
Die verkaufen die Software, die verkaufen Support, die verkaufen Jahresabos, CPU, kernbasierte Lizenzen oder whatever, plus jeder Mitarbeiter muss teure Schulungen, über 5000 Euro teure Schulungen besuchen.
Das ist so eine Scheiße, das ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken für die.
Kennst du den Film Delta Force mit Chuck Norris?
Ich glaube sogar, ich kenne den Film.
Bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Ich kenne ein paar Filme.
Ich kenne ein paar Filme mit Chuck Norris.
Mir ist ehrlich gesagt keiner der Filme großartig in Erinnerung geblieben.
Mit Chuck Norris.
Kann ich dich fragen? Kannst du fragen?
Ich habe 2007 Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt.
Könnte man auch als Quereinsteiger in die IT-Szene reinkommen?
Ja klar, wenn du dich auskennst.
Die Chancen sind aktuell so gut wie noch nie für Quereinsteiger.
Du musst, naja, also Quereinsteiger, ohne dass du irgendwie was vorzuweisen hast und ohne dass du dich mit was auskennst.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast, willst du in die IT, dann wäre eine Ausbildung vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Das ist ja auch in gehobenerem Alter kein Problem.
Ja, wir hatten einen in der Klasse, der war glaube ich 35 oder so.
Das ist auch schon eine Weile her.
Und das ist, also es ist kein Problem.
Du musst halt, wenn du wirklich Quereinsteiger sein, wenn du wirklich Quereinsteiger bist und willst einstellen, musst du halt auch was können, was die Leute suchen.
Ja, also wenn du das kannst, dann ist das kein Problem.
Wenn du, wenn du sagst, ich will eigentlich nur einsteigen und hab selbst noch keine Ahnung, dann ist eine Ausbildung wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante.
Wenn man nach der Ausbildung immer noch nichts weiß, das ist nicht so wild.
Dann hast du einen Zettel, wo draufsteht, dass du was weißt.
Das System outplayed.
Dann musst du nichts mehr wissen.
Wobei das ja natürlich nicht stimmt.
Das fällt früher oder später, sagen wir mal, je nachdem, in welchem Unternehmen du landest, fällt das früher oder später auf.
Ja.
Es mag durchaus Unternehmen geben, dann fällt es nie auf.
Und man sagt, oder man könnte fast sagen, bei manchen Unternehmen ist es eigentlich normal, dass eigentlich keiner was kann.
Aber, wenn du bei einem halbwegs gescheiten Laden bist, die auch was von dir wollen, dann fällt das über früher, über kurz oder lang auf.
Wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast.
Und ich sag auch ganz ehrlich, keine Ahnung haben ist keine Schande.
Ich hab, ich, mir ist auch bewusst, dass ich von viel, viel mehr Sachen, auch IT-technisch, ja.
Von viel, viel mehr Sachen keine Ahnung hab, wie das ich Ahnung hab.
Das muss man auch erstmal erkennen.
Aber zumindest für die Sachen, wo die jemanden suchen und du sagst, du kennst dich aus, solltest du zumindest ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Wenn ja einer was, wenn dann einer was von dir will.
Ist in dem IT-Bereich, das, das IT-Bereich, IT-Bereich ist so umfangreich, dass es so, wie wenn ich sagen würde, ähm, wie hab ich, was hab ich heute auf Reddit gelesen, das war ein guter, war ein guter Vergleich.
Da hat einer auf Reddit heute einen Post rausgehauen.
Da ging es genau in den Bereich.
So nach dem Motto, warum sagen die Leute immer, ich arbeite in der IT?
Ja.
Das sind genauso wie die Leute, die immer sagen, du machst doch was mit Computer.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn, wie wenn du fragen würdest, ja, arbeitest du im, äh, im Holz, arbeitest du mit Holz?
Arbeitest du mit Holz?
Das kann alles sein.
Du kannst Verkäufer bei Ikea sein.
Du kannst, ähm, und ich zitiere jetzt nur Red Hat.
Äh, nicht Red Hat, lul, also.
Ich, ich zitiere jetzt nur Reddit.
Du kannst aber auch Dildos schnitzen auf dem Wochenmarkt verkaufen.
Kannst aber auch Oberförster sein.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das ist enorm vielfältig.
Und genauso ist es im Bereich IT auch.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nur Reddit zitiert.
So, genauso ist es im IT-Bereich auch.
Es kommt drauf an, wo du bist, was wichtig ist.
Ich kann dir aber eine Sache sagen, die mit Abstand am wichtigsten ist.
Und das ist googeln können.
Das ist der mit Abstand, egal in welchem Bereich.
Und das geht wahrscheinlich weit über IT raus.
Im, der mit Abstand wichtigste Skills ist, dass man googeln kann.
Gehört zu den mit wichtigsten Skills.
Norlaus Penketz, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente.
Subscription.
Nice.
Also googeln ist ohne Scheiß das Wichtigste, was es gibt.
Embedded Entwickler.
Mir fällt ein Embedded Entwickler ein, der ist aber grad nicht da.
Und ob der sich mit NXP microcontrolliert?
Hab ich keine Ahnung.
Was haben die Leute vor Google gemacht?
Chat, braucht ihr History-Lesson, was Suchmaschinen angeht?
Da kann ich nämlich ein bisschen wie der Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg machen.
Also, was haben die Leute, was haben die Leute gemacht, bevor es Google gab?
Manche Leute, manche Leute haben sowas wie Yahoo verwendet als Index.
So als quasi, so als Art Telefonbuch fürs Internet.
Manche Leute haben Yahoo verwendet, aber es gab davor auch schon Suchmaschinen.
Da gab es zum Beispiel Fireball.de.
Ich geb das jetzt nicht ein, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob es das noch gibt und ich weiß nicht, wo man da rauskommt, wenn man das eingibt.
Fireball war zum Beispiel eine deutsche Suchmaschine.
Dann gab es noch Lycos, gibt es die noch?
Gab es auch noch vor Google.
Ja.
Ja genau, da sind die mit diesem Google.
Dann gab es noch einen komischen Hund da als Logo, der sich, der jedes Mal anders aussieht, wenn man sich das Logo anschaut.
Dann, ähm, hattest du noch sowas wie Alta Vista.
Genau, gab es auch noch.
Und leicht abgewandelter Schreibweise gab es auch noch eine Suchmaschine für Grauzonen-legale Sachen.
Die hieß so ähnlich.
Damals sind übrigens auch noch viele Leute in Foren und Newsgroups gegangen für Infos.
Erinnert sich noch irgendeiner an das Gulli-Forum?
Oldschool-Leute mögen sich noch erinnern.
Kennt noch einer von euch, jetzt mal ernsthaft, kennt noch einer das Gulli-Forum?
Oder das Gulli-Board hieß das ja, Gulli-Board.
IRC, IRC ist Hackermans-Kram, das hat, das haben die 015-Leute, haben nicht IRC verwendet.
Das Gulli-Board, das gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Ja.
Das haben die, das haben die Leute vor Google gemacht.
Aber wisst ihr was, viel lustig.
Aber wisst ihr was, viel lustiger ist?
Was Google angeht.
Wusstet ihr, dass Yahoo dafür hätte sorgen können, dass es Google in der Form nie gegeben hätte, beziehungsweise heute nicht mehr gibt?
Die Gründer von Google sind mit ihrer Idee und der Technologie, wie man quasi Google, also die Such-, ich rede bei Google, rede ich jetzt nur von der Suchmaschine, ja.
Ich rede nicht von diesem gesamten Konstrukt Google, was da sonst noch so, nur von der Suchmaschine.
Die zwei Gründer von Google sind damals zu Yahoo.
Und wollten denen ihre Google Search, Search-Technologie verkaufen für, ich glaube, 2 Millionen damals.
Für ein Appel und Ei für Yahoo.
Dann hat Yahoo gesagt, ach nee, brauchen wir nicht.
So, dann haben die gesagt, ja gut, scheiß auf Yahoo, wir machen unsere eigene Suchmaschine.
Und dann hätten sie ein paar Jahre später nochmal die Chance gehabt, für dann aber schon, keine Ahnung, 80 Millionen oder so, Google zu kaufen.
Und die haben es immer noch nicht gemacht.
Und heute ist Yahoo am Arsch.
Weiß gar nicht, wem das mittlerweile gehört.
Da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu alt.
Ich kenne die Rede wenigstens noch nicht, aber fumbled kann ich mir vorstellen.
So verhaspelt halt, oder beziehungsweise so verfummelt kann man.
Wie, wie, was heißt denn fumbled?
Ich weiß, was es bedeutet, ja.
Das ist, wenn du halt was nicht, was nicht auf die Reihe kriegst.
Weil, das hast du zum Beispiel bei MMOs.
Ja, wenn du fumbles, dann musst du eine Attack-Runde aussetzen oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, was fumbled so direkt übersetzt heißt.
Was heißt fumbled direkt Deutsch?
Das ist doch gar nicht so falsch, was ich gesagt habe.
Ist doch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Die Japaner benutzen noch tatsächlich Yahoo.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wo liegt deines Erachtens nach das Gehalt eines SysAdmins mit fünf Jahren Berufserfahrung?
Das kommt darauf an, in welcher Branche und in welchem Gebiet du bist.
Also mit Gebiet meine ich jetzt Region, nicht Gebiet.
Ja, Gebiet auch ein bisschen.
Also, ich persönlich habe den Eindruck, Linux-Leute verdienen einen Ticken mehr als Windows-Leute.
Was vielleicht daran...
Also, mein Eindruck, ja.
Was vielleicht daran liegen könnte, dass es nicht so viele gescheite Linux-Leute gibt, wie Windows-Leute.
Es kommt darauf an, welcher Arbeitgeber, welche Region.
Ja, was du so kannst.
Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen.
Es ist schwer, schwer zu sagen.
Es gibt Leute, die machen als Admin nichts anderes, wie den ganzen Tag Passwörter resetten von irgendwelchen User-Accounts im AD.
Da würde ich jetzt auch nicht so viel ausgeben.
Wenn es meine Firma wäre.
Magst du, wenn du neues IT-Gedöns nennst, nutzt du dafür aktiv einen Notiz-App wie Obsidian?
Ja, ich benutze...
Moment.
Ich benutze das.
Aber...
Ach, ich habe es doch hier sogar auf.
Lul.
Ich benutze das.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, so hundertprozentig glücklich bin ich damit auch nicht.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich das verwende, nach Jahren jetzt auch noch, ja, ich habe das ja schon lange,
ist, weil es das für Windows, Linux und IOS gibt und weil es Notifications kann.
Du kannst quasi auf einer Plattform sagen, ja, dieser Task ist fällig 23.10.21 Uhr und dann unterstützt das Notifications auf allen Plattformen.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch.
So toll finde ich es nicht.
Obsidian finde ich auf den ersten Blick hübscher.
Und es gibt ja 30 Milliarden Notizen.
Notiz-Apps.
Confluence.
Ja, Confluence ist kein, finde ich, ist nicht gescheit, um Notizen zu schreiben.
Confluence dauert alles so lang.
Du musst einen Browser aufmachen, musst Confluence aufmachen, musst eine Seite aufmachen, wo du was reinschreibst.
Confluence ist vielleicht nice, wenn du Collaborated Editing machen...
Kann man das so nennen?
Alter, ich könnte auch sagen, wenn du mit anderen Leuten zusammen eine Seite bearbeiten willst oder sowas.
So Wiki-mäßig, so Knowledge-Base-mäßig vielleicht für irgendwie ein Team oder sowas.
Aber für mich alleine finde ich Confluence zu aufwendig und es dauert zu lang von ich habe einen Gedanken im Kopf bis er steht irgendwo.
Ich habe früher viel Doku-Wiki verwendet, aber das hat ähnliche Probleme.
Notizprogramm ist halt besser.
Das hast du auf dem Shortcut, ja, und hast die auf und schreibst rein und zack.
Du musst noch nicht mal safen.
Sobald es schließt, ist es halt einfach gespeichert.
Das ist halt einfach...
Wie sagt man so schön heute?
Low Friction.
Das geht schnell von Gedanke im Kopf zu Gedanke ist notiert.
Das dauert bei Confluence einfach ewig.
Ja, mache ich auch.
Zumindest wenn ich hier schnell was aufschreiben muss.
Kann man auch machen.
Letztendlich braucht man irgendein System, wo man selbst mit klarkommt.
Der Rest ist egal.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Das sagt mir nichts.
Aber es gibt...
Ich glaube, Notizprogramm ist eines der häufigsten Software-Typen, die es so gibt.
Es gibt tausende.
Es gibt tausend Milliarden solcher Notizprogramme.
Hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Wenn du nach Nodes und sonst was bei GitHub suchst, das sind...
Ja, das sind tausende.
Übrigens habt ihr gesehen?
Svelte 5 wurde released.
Aber...
Die Docs-Seite gibt es doch nicht.
Die Docs-Seite ist noch Preview und noch kaputt.
Aber Svelte 5 ist released.
Wir müssen uns demnächst auch angucken.
Ich hab mal wieder Bock auf sinnlosen Frontend-Stelze.
Ein bisschen kämpfen mit CSS.
Das benutze ich auch.
Guck hier oben.
Da ist es.
Ja.
Haben wir schon.
Ich weiß.
Ja.
Da hast du recht.
Wie kamst du auf den Beruf?
Du meinst, warum ich 2007 Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt habe?
Oder was meinst du?
Naja.
Ja.
Schon.
Auch.
Also.
Das ist tatsächlich gehört zur Wahrheit dabei.
Meine Mutter hat Stress gemacht.
Mein Vater auch.
Aber damit habe ich ja nicht allzu viel zu tun.
Ja.
Also.
Mein Ziel war eigentlich nach der Schule mein restliches Leben MMO zu spielen den ganzen Tag.
War mein Wunschgedanke.
Aber ich wusste, dass das natürlich nicht geht.
Ja.
Ich wollte den ganzen Tag MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen.
Wäre sinnvoll gewesen, ne?
Das Problem ist, dass da meine Eltern was dagegen hatten.
Und die haben mich genervt.
Und dann habe ich erst Zivildienst gemacht.
Ich habe, das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, ich hätte fast was mit BWL gelernt.
Aber ich habe mich dann doch besonnen, dass das Schrott ist.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich mal geguckt.
Was kann man denn mit Computer so machen?
Ich war ja schon immer so richtig hier der Hacker-Mans.
Ich habe beispielsweise Programmieren gelernt.
Just for fun.
2001, 2002.
Nur für mich, ohne dass es mich großartig irgendwie beruflich weitergebracht hat.
Ich habe damals gelernt.
Ich habe angefangen mit tatsächlich C-Sharp.net unter Windows.
Und ich habe damals auch ein bisschen Python 2.3 oder was das damals war.
Oder 2.5 war glaube ich ganz neu gerade.
Und dann habe ich dann angefangen.
Also.
Das habe ich gerade ein bisschen gemacht.
Damit habe ich Programmieren gelernt.
Natürlich ist man nie fertig lernen muss man gerade.
Also gerade was Software entwickeln ist man nie fertig lernen.
Aber zumindest die Basics habe ich damals gelernt.
Das hat mir auch echt viel Spaß gemacht.
Und dann habe ich geguckt.
Was es denn so für Ausbildungsberufe gibt.
Und was denn bei uns in der Nähe.
Beziehungsweise was es überhaupt an Ausbildungsstellen gibt.
Man darf nicht vergessen.
2006, 2007 war noch eine ganz andere Zeit.
Damals war es so.
Nicht so wie heute.
Dass die eigentlich kaum noch Azubis finden die das machen wollen.
Damals war das so.
Es sind gefühlt 50 Azubis auf eine Ausbildungsstelle gekommen.
Also.
Ich kann euch das jetzt nicht statistisch belegen oder so.
Aber es waren andere Zeiten was das angeht.
Es war deutlich schwieriger.
Und.
Ich hatte aber Glück wie immer.
Ohne Scheiß Leute.
Ich habe.
Okay.
Gehen wir mal nur von meiner Seite.
Gehen wir mal nur von meiner IT Laufbahn aus.
Ja.
Was meint ihr wie viel Bewerbung ich in meinem gesamten Leben IT technisch.
Für IT Jobs geschrieben habe.
Inklusive Ausbildung.
Ich zähle selbst mal nach.
Ja es sind drei oder vier.
Je nachdem wie man es nennt.
Wie man es nimmt.
Drei oder vier.
Und zwar.
Ich habe zwei Bewerbungen für die Ausbildungsstelle geschrieben.
Eines war für Anwendungsentwicklung.
Den hatte ich damals auch ein bisschen.
Python.
Beispiel Code von mir mitgeschickt.
Und das war aber ein Drecksladen.
Das habe ich dann rausgekriegt.
Bin froh dass es nichts geworden ist.
Ja gut.
Ob die so schlimm waren.
Man weiß es ja im Endeffekt auch nicht.
Wenn man selbst nicht da war.
Zumindest die haben sich.
Die haben sich.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob die sich nicht gemeldet haben.
Ich hatte.
Als ich heimgekommen bin.
Damals.
Einen unbeantworteten Anruf.
Auf dem Anrufbeantworter.
Ich wusste aber nicht von welcher Nummer.
Aber normalerweise hat mich damals eigentlich keiner angerufen.
Und.
Danach hat sich nie wieder einer von denen gemeldet.
Also entweder waren die das.
Und wollen absagen.
Oder sind einfach ein richtiger Drecksladen gewesen.
Die sich nie melden nach einer Bewerbung.
Wie dem auch immer.
Ist auch vollkommen egal.
Die zweite Bewerbung.
In Frankfurt.
Hat.
Direkt.
Gezogen.
Und.
Die haben mich eingeladen.
Zum Vorstellungsgespräch.
Und das habe ich.
Die Story habe ich euch noch oft genug erzählt.
Jetzt.
Und dann hat das funktioniert.
Und.
Das war es.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Wisst ihr was.
Ich habe gerade mal im Anhang.
Dann habe ich eine Ausbildung angefangen.
Fachinformatiker System Integration beim Provider.
Danach bin ich.
Gewechselt zu einer Bank.
Wobei das halt auch Glück.
War also.
Wie gesagt.
222 Bewerbung habe ich geschrieben Für die für Die Ausbildung.
Und jetzt ist es Das die Frage zählt Das nächste als Bewerbung.
Und zwar.
Damals war es so.
Ich.
Habe meine Ausbildung gemacht.
Hab.
Danach auch noch dort.
quasi das verlängert.
Ich habe dann danach einen ganz normalen Vertrag unterschrieben.
Ich kann euch sagen, weil ich damals, mein erster
Arbeitsvertrag, da habe ich 33.500
Euro im Jahr bekommen.
Heute kriege ich das
ja, ungefähr das
dreifache ungefähr.
Mit 80%. Stimmt nicht ganz,
das ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Sagen wir mal das 2,8
2,7
2,8-fache. Also ich verdiene
ungefähr mit
mit
mit Bonus, mit Bonuszahlung,
mit Gedöns und allem und Rufbereitschaftskram
so um die 90k.
In dem Dreh so ungefähr.
Plus, Minus. Und das bei
80%. Also es ist ungefähr
verdreifacht.
Seitdem.
Und ich habe dann
relativ schnell gemerkt, dass
mein Ausbildungsladen ein ziemlicher Kackladen
ist. Und zwar habe ich auch ein Video
zugemacht. Also wenn sich das einer von euch angucken
will, der die Story noch nicht kennt.
Das Video heißt, wenn der Chef
euch verarscht oder sowas.
Ähm.
Äh.
Tja. Es ist toll,
dass
meine Videos nicht richtig gefunden werden.
Das kann aber
auch sein. Ich glaube, das Video
hieß anders.
Ja, ich finde mein Video nicht, aber das
Wer interessiert, was in meinem
ehemaligen Ausbildungsbetrieb abgegangen ist,
der kann sich
dieses Video hier mal angucken.
Das müsste wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger her sein.
Ich erkenne das sofort, wenn ich
sehe. Aber war das nicht schön, Zeiten,
wo ich mal Videos gemacht habe?
Kek. W.
HD. XD.
Ja, das da.
Solo.
Ja, das ist das Video.
13 Minuten. Da habe ich mich ein bisschen drüber
ausgelassen, was das eigentlich für ein Kackladen ist,
wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Also wer es genau wissen will, kann sich das Video angucken.
Zumindest,
und das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das,
das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das als Bewerbung
zählt. Und zwar, als ich
damals keinen Bock mehr auf den Job
beim Provider hatte,
das war halt so. Ich habe damals bei
einer Bank gearbeitet in Frankfurt. Allerdings,
ich war noch beim Provider angestellt.
Die hatten quasi dort
ein Rechenzentrum, mehrere Rechenzentren
in Frankfurt. Eins davon war halt quasi
von der Bank.
Und das haben wir betrieben.
Das heißt, wir kannten die Leute, die kannten
uns. Und die haben uns irgendwann mal gefragt,
ob wir nicht Bock haben, anstatt
dass die uns für
irgendwie, was weiß ich, 20.000 Euro
oder so, einkaufen beim Provider,
ob wir nicht Bock haben, direkt bei denen
zu arbeiten. Da gab es Probleme,
weil die Bank und der
Provider quasi unterschrieben haben,
dass die irgendwie sich keine Leute
abwerben und solche Geschichten.
Da ist übrigens unser Embedded-Entwickler,
falls ihr da...
Irgendjemand wollte vorhin was
wegen Embedded-Entwicklung. Habe ich gesagt, wir haben
einen, aber der ist gerade nicht da.
So, und
die haben uns dann gefragt,
inklusive, also mit uns
meine ich, mich und die anderen, die damals
auch quasi das Gleiche da gemacht haben,
ob wir nicht zu ihnen
wollen, aber
der Form halber müssen wir den Lebenslauf
abgeben, weil die das für die Personalakte haben
wollen. Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das wirklich
als Bewerbung durchgeht.
Keine Ahnung. So halb.
So halb.
Wenn das zählt,
dann war das die dritte Bewerbung.
Also ist das wirklich eine Bewerbung?
Also ich muss kein Vorstellungsgespräch in der klassischen Form machen.
Zählen wir es mit, waren es drei Bewerbungen.
Dann habe ich mich nochmal beworben.
Auf eine Stelle in Würzburg.
Da hatte ich auch schon
Vorstellungsgespräch und da hatte ich den
Vertrag in der Post. Das ist, als ich dann von der Bank
wechseln wollte. Und
stimmt nicht, sogar fünf Bewerbungen.
So halb. Weil meinen aktuellen
Job bei der Versicherung,
den habe ich ja auch um
erstens überhaupt nur gefunden,
weil dort jemand arbeitet, den ich kenne.
Und ich musste mich,
ja, ich musste ein Vorstellungsgespräch machen.
Dann waren es fünf Bewerbungen.
Wenn man die eine abzieht, vier,
die ich je geschrieben habe.
Also ich hatte Ultra-Glück, was das
angeht.
Man könnte auch sagen, ich war
einfach so überzeugend
und pro,
dass die alle erkannt haben,
den wollen wir direkt haben.
Ich könnte aber einfach nur Glück gehabt haben.
Nee, das hat damals nicht funktioniert.
Also nicht, dass man
hätte als Pro-Gamer Millionen machen können.
Da haben ja ein paar gezeigt, dass das potenziell geht.
Wenn auch nur ganz, ganz wenige.
Aber das hätte
die, glaube ich, nicht überzeugt.
Die Chance
ASP.net
mit Svelte zu ver...
Da brauche ich keine
Templates für. Das habe ich so schon oft gemacht.
Svelte V3,
Keck Wait, was ist denn mit denen los?
Roll-Up-App?
Wie alt ist denn das, bitteschön?
Das ist ja uralt.
V3 und Roll-Up. Heute ist es Welt 5 mit Veed.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Das ist outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Das Template.
Aber das habe ich schon oft gemacht. Da brauche ich kein Template für.
Einfach mal fragen, wie alt ich bin.
40.
Auch ja, manchmal denke ich, ich bin 29
vielleicht, ja.
Wir hatten damals 10 Azubi-Stellen, knapp 200 Bewerbungen.
Ja, du meinst so in dem Dreh 2007
rum. Das war richtig krass.
Damals war es generell schwierig.
Also da gab es auch... Ich glaube, das war die Zeit, wo es mal
in der jüngeren
Geschichte von Deutschland
die höchsten Arbeitslosenzahlen gab.
Ich hätte ja gerne auch ein bisschen
geharzt. Damals.
Damals bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob man das
schon geharzt nannte.
Beziehungsweise heute heißt es ja
eigentlich gar nicht mehr geharzt.
Heute heißt es ja gebürgergeldet
oder sowas.
Ich hätte damals auch gerne ein bisschen
geharzt, aber
meine Eltern haben mich
viel zu sehr genervt mit
hier und mach mal da.
Irgendwann, wie gesagt, nach Zivildienst
und meiner blöden Idee,
was BWL-mäßig ist...
Das ist doch bescheuert, Alter. Wie kann man auf so eine dämliche Idee kommen,
was BWL-mäßig ist, zu machen?
Habe ich dann 2007
die Ausbildung gemacht zum
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Ich durfte nicht Bürgergeld
Oh, ich dachte da Go benutze.
Da habe ich mich so dran gewöhnt.
Muss ja nicht Google noch mehr mitteilen.
Microsoft macht geheimes Zeug.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Das war in meinem
Ausbildungsbetrieb so. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich auf meinen Ausbildungsbetrieb
beziehst, aber das war da auch ungefähr so.
Die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter war gefühlt Azubis.
Wollte mein Vater, dass ich bei ihm ins
Business einsteige. Das Business von
meinem Vater, was ich euch erzählt habe,
damals, wo er die Leute gescapt hat,
das gab es damals
schon nicht mehr.
Das war in den 90ern irgendwann.
Ich bin seit...
Ja, ist schon
ein paar Monate jetzt.
Bin ich 40.
Ja, am Wochenende.
Wer hat da die Leute gescapt?
Das erzähle ich jetzt nicht nochmal.
Das habe ich ausführlich letzten oder vorletzten
Stream erzählt.
Das kann ich nicht jeden Stream erzählen.
Ich sage es ganz kurz.
Mein Vater hatte
Pre-Internet.
Damals gab es
noch 90er, Anfang 90er.
Gab es, hatte keiner Internet.
Hatte eine Partnervermittlung
in Frankfurt.
Und hat Omas gescapt.
Der hat im Prinzip
gar keine Partner vermittelt.
Der hat denen Geld abgeknöpft für Monatsbeiträge.
Und hat sehr, sehr
unvorteilhafte Verträge gestaltet
für die. Und der hatte dann
quasi einen Pool aus...
Ja, wahrscheinlich...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die ausgeschaut haben.
Der hatte dann einen Pool aus, sagen wir mal,
netten,
wortgewandten, gutaussehenden Herren.
Die sind dann alle zu den Omas
daheim, haben denen schöne Augen gemacht,
aber waren sich nicht so sicher
und sonst wie.
Sodass die Omas möglichst schön lange Monatsbeiträge
bezahlen.
Und das hat geklappt.
Der hat fetteste Kohle gemacht.
Zumindest für eine Zeit lang.
Fetteste Kohle.
Und im gleichen Zuge,
Moment, Moment,
bevor sich das jetzt so anhört,
als hätte der fetteste Kohle gemacht
und ich hätte von der fetten Kohle was ab.
Das funktioniert heute noch ähnlich
bei Partnervermittlung, natürlich.
Überlegt euch mal, welcher Anreiz
hat eine Partnervermittlung, die mit
Monatsgebühren was sich finanziert,
Leute zu vermitteln. Also ich habe nichts gesehen
von der Kohle.
Und die Kohle ist mittlerweile heute auch komplett weg.
Der hat nämlich
meine Mutter und mich damals sitzen lassen
und
hat zu meiner Mutter gesagt,
müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen,
jemand der wirklich super krass fett Kohle macht
für die damalige Zeit, überlegt euch mal,
über 10.000 Mark im Monat,
was das Anfang der 90er, das war extrem
viel Geld, extrem viel Geld.
Also richtig viel Geld.
Und der hat zu meiner Mutter gesagt,
er kann keinen Unterhalt bezahlen.
Heute wäre das noch sehr viel Geld.
Er hat zu meiner Mutter gesagt,
ich kann keinen Unterhalt
bezahlen für mein Kind, weil ich brauche
erstmal 10.000 Mark im Monat für mich.
Richtiger Business
Macher, würde man da heute zu sagen.
Aber,
er war leider etwas zu viel
der Macher.
Das Ganze ging nicht zu seinen
Vorteilen aus am Ende.
Seine Business-Geschichten.
Das machen bestimmt sicherlich die meisten
Partnervermittlungsseiten heute immer noch.
Bestimmt
alles korrekt besteuert auch.
Naja, wie gesagt,
ich habe es das letzte Mal ausführlicher,
das Alpha, das Sigma
Crime-Set,
ich habe es das letzte Mal ein bisschen ausführlich
erzählt. Er hat eben nicht
alles korrekt versteuert.
Und ich kann euch sagen,
als Kind,
auch wenn man nicht
das beste Verhältnis zu
seinem Vater hat,
man hat ja irgendwie immer noch ein bisschen so
im Hinterkopf, das ist sein Vater und so.
Wenn euch der Vater aus
Untersuchungshaft anruft,
weil er alles zu korrekt besteuert
hat,
das merkt ihr euch für den Rest eures Lebens,
kann ich euch sagen.
Deswegen,
mache ich auch, was Steuer angeht,
alles extrem korrekt.
Ich hatte am ersten
Tag, wo ich hier
das Gewerbe
angemeldet habe, seit dem ersten Tag hatte ich einen Steuerberater
am Start und der macht das alles.
Er ist
übrigens, muss dazu sagen,
er ist freigesprochen worden
für sein Scambusiness. Also kann man
offiziell eigentlich gar nicht mal wirklich behaupten,
es wäre Scam gewesen, weil
es wurde gerichtlich
festgestellt, es war
er wurde nicht verurteilt, wo man sagen muss,
okay, nicht verurteilt,
vor über 10 Jahren schon,
also ist er auch
kein Scammer, moralisch
vielleicht, rechtlich gesehen nicht
und verurteilt wurde
er meines Wissens nach nie.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das läuft
mit Steuern,
zumindest musste er halt
sehr, sehr viel nachbezahlen
am Ende und das ganze
Business war weg.
Und, by the way, jetzt wenn ich
Love Scam lese,
by the way, heute
scammt ja nicht mehr die Leute, heute wird
er gescampt.
Mein Vater hat eine 26, also mein Vater ist
äh, 75
glaube ich,
und er hat eine Freundin, die ist
26.
Also erzählt er immer.
Bis ich dann irgendwann rausgekriegt habe,
naja, so eine richtige Freundin
ist das nicht, das ist ein Love Scam,
aus der Karibik,
die halt ihm schöne Augen macht
dafür, dass er ab und zu
ein bisschen Geld überweist.
Nee, Karibik, nicht Philippinen.
Und ich habe ihm
das auch erzählt, ich habe ihn gefragt, Papa,
meinst du wirklich
eine 26-Jährige aus
der Karibik hat nur drauf gewartet,
dass ein 75-Jähriger Opa
aus Deutschland da jetzt
irgendwie große Macker macht, oder
wie? Ja, und er ist wirklich der Meinung,
die haben alle nur auf ihn gewartet, dass er den
mal zeigt, was für ein geiler Hecht er noch ist mit 75.
Keine Ahnung,
ich würde eigentlich davon ausgehen,
so krass wie der früher die Leute gescamt
hat, durchschaut da sowas
meilenweit, aber anscheinend nicht.
Oh, guck mal, Leute,
Leute, guck mal, wir haben
wir haben vor
43 Minuten geupdatet, Arch by the way,
es wird Zeit, nächstes Update.
Eigentlich muss man
überhaupt nicht rebooten danach, macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn, was habe ich nochmal geupdatet?
Irgendwelche, keine Ahnung,
nichts, wofür man rebooten muss.
Eigentlich muss man null rebooten dafür.
So,
jetzt habe ich die Story auch nochmal erzählt.
Gut, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Eigentlich gar nichts, eigentlich
Laberstream, ne? Wir machen gar
nichts, großartig.
Ich bin es gar nicht gewöhnt, Leute.
Ich war jetzt
die letzten Jahre,
habe ich, ich bin 1,74
und habe 108,5 Kilo gewogen,
ja? So,
und seit,
ich weiß nicht
genau, bisschen
so zu Corona rum hat es angefangen.
Wo alle Leute zugenommen haben, habe ich angefangen
abzunehmen. Mittlerweile wiege ich
280 Kilo. Ich weiß, ich habe
auf Twitter ein Bild gepostet,
80,5, das war nach
dem Rennen und ohne zu essen und nach dem
Klo und allem, aber das waren 280
Kilo und
es ist mir jetzt schon öfters passiert,
was die letzten Jahre
eigentlich wusste ich, wusste ich gar nicht
mehr, dass das überhaupt, wie das so ist,
ja? Mir ist jetzt schon öfters passiert,
dass gerade, wenn ich morgens früh
hier mal eine Runde renne,
gerade wenn ich die Runde so renne, dass ich durch
die ganzen neuen Siedlungsgebiete
durchkomme und
ähm
da gehen halt noch mehr Leute joggen, ja?
Und da gehen auch sehr viele
Mädels joggen und
gerade wenn, ja, naja, ob die mir
hinter, das glaube ich jetzt eher weniger,
aber das hatte ich schon die letzten
Wochen öfters mal, dass man da morgens
an sich vorbei und sich tatsächlich so
was wie angelächelt hat. Stellt euch das mal
vor.
Vor allem
während man am Rennen
ist und je nachdem wie anstrengend
das ist mit dem Rennen, ist das gar nicht so einfach.
Ab 40 wird jeder fetter, egal was man,
ich bin jetzt 40. Ich bin aber,
das Gegenteil, das
Gegenteil ist bei mir gerade.
Hahaha.
Dazu müsste ich ja erstmal auf,
also erstmal müsste ich da
wieder eine haben, mit der ich auf das Festival
gehe. Und zweitens
müsste ich dann auch noch wirklich auf das Festival
gehen. Und ich glaube
heute würde ich
das wahrscheinlich etwas,
ja, nicht so
unterirdisch handhaben wie damals.
Max ist in der
besten Form seines Lebens. Ja, das stimmt.
Ich war noch nie so fit wie jetzt.
Hast du in der Zwischenzeit eigentlich
ein neues Fahrrad? Klar!
Schon seit ein paar Monaten.
Hier, mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Fahrrad.
Ich kann ja mal schreiben.
Ja, ist doch. Zack.
Ist immer noch down.
Wo kommt denn das wieder?
Sätge.
Ja gut, habe ich nicht.
Ja, ich habe wieder ein Fahrrad.
Ich hätte es dir jetzt auch gezeigt,
aber gibt es ja nicht.
Was sagen die denn auf X?
Moment, am 23.
Das ist doch heute.
Die wurden schon wieder gehackt. Die hatten vergessen,
einen Token zu... Ernsthaft?
Nicht schon wieder, oder?
Internet Archive ist eine der wichtigsten Seiten.
Das muss ein Back sein.
So schnell wie es geht.
Aber ja, ich habe mir ein neues Fahrrad gekauft.
Ich habe wieder von Rose1.
Ich habe im Prinzip das gleiche Fahrrad wie das letzte Mal.
Nur, dass ich jetzt eine
11 Schaltung anstatt eine 1x11 Schaltung habe.
Ich habe ein Rose Backroad.
Ja, im Prinzip das hier.
Ups.
Oh, es gibt was Neues.
Es gibt jetzt...
Haben die es wirklich...
Es gibt jetzt tatsächlich die GRX Sache auch.
Die neuen auch als Di2.
Moment, ne.
Das ist nicht die Gravel.
Das ist die Racing.
Schon wieder was Neues.
Auch ein bisschen teurer als meins.
Minimal, minimal teurer.
Doppelt so viel wie meins.
Rotten Candy.
Okay, das hat irgendwie was.
Geil, wie die sein.
Was sind denn jetzt die Standard...
Das muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Was sind denn da jetzt so die Standard
Kassetten und vorne?
Wie viele Ausstattungen?
Okay, kommt mit
Carbonräder.
Ach ne, Moment. Ja doch.
Ähm...
34.
Das ist zwölffach,
aber nur bis 34 wahrscheinlich.
Das ist das einzige was...
Das ist ja doof.
Ich mein 31 zu 34 kommt zumindest schon
halbwegs gut den Bash hoch.
Aber für mich darf es ruhig noch ein bisschen easier sein.
Wie lange ging das jetzt vom Unfall
bis zum neuen Fahrrad?
Ähm...
Unfall hatte ich letztes Jahr ungefähr zu dieser Zeit.
Und Neues gekauft
war ich schon ein paar Monate her.
Also ich würde sagen, so ein...
Ne, wobei, das war noch
ein Monat früher, letztes Jahr, wo ich den Unfall hatte.
Ich würde sagen, so...
Also bis ich
das ganze Geld hatte, ein dreiviertel Jahr.
Wie das...
Ja, ein dreiviertel Jahr, bis ich das ganze Geld hatte
von der Versicherung. Aber ich hab mir ja schon
ein neues Fahrrad gekauft, bevor ich
das Geld komplett von der Versicherung hatte.
Ich hab ein Foto gepostet.
Wirklich?
Ah, da muss man jetzt ja x.com machen, weil Twitter
geht ja nicht mehr. Ja.
Genau, da ist noch das Fahrrad.
Ja, genau, genau, genau.
Ja. Das ist das Fahrrad, was ich mir
gekauft hab. Ich hab richtig Glück gehabt.
Ich hab noch das letzte
Modell in meiner Rahmengröße bekommen.
Und ich hab dann auch...
Ich hab, glaub, nur knapp 2000 Euro
bezahlt dafür. Das war richtig runtergesetzt.
Weil Rose quasi die
alten 11-fach
Di2-Schaltungen weghaben wollte.
Aber es juckt mich nett.
Ja, wunderbar. Immer noch nices Fahrrad.
Und für 2000 Euro ist es wirklich
preis-leistungsmöglich. Super Fahrrad.
Ich hab ein bisschen...
Ich hab ein bisschen gemoddet.
Ich hab hinten beispielsweise die Kassette ausgetauscht.
Durch eine größere.
Die Konfiguration wird offiziell von
Shimano nicht supported.
Aber es geht trotzdem.
Es ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr nices Fahrrad.
Das werde ich auch noch lange fahren.
Sofern ich nicht wieder umgefahren werde.
Packingbremse, oldschool
Sache hier. Aber
gewachste Kette, Leute.
Ne, ne. Die Custom Garmin App hab ich nie
fertig gebaut.
Die hab ich nie fertig gebaut. Aber ich hab ne ähnliche Garmin App
gefunden, wie das, was ich bauen wollte.
Dass man mehr
quasi
mehr Sensoren anzeigen lassen kann auf
kleiner Fläche.
Hab ich jetzt drauf.
Ich hab eh, glaub ich...
Ja, das war eigentlich ganz nice.
Das könnten wir vielleicht irgendwann nochmal weitermachen.
Oder was anderes bauen.
Ich hab das Ding ja eh aufgerüstet.
Also auf der Halterung für
alles mögliche mit dabei.
Ich hab nen
Rücklicht, was
nen Radar eingebaut hat.
Und mir Autos anzeigen lassen kann.
Also ich bekomm ne Warnung auf meinem
Garmin, wenn Autos von hinten kommen und sowas.
Ähm
Ich kann ne Handy drauf machen.
Also ich meistens, meistens
fahre ich mit
dem Garmin Fahrradcomputer vorne drauf.
Plus meinem Handy für
Navigation aufm
ja
da auf der Lenkerhalterung.
Weil Handy ist einfach für Navigation
beste. Viel besseres
Display, reagiert viel schneller
und die Garmin Kiste
ist halt einfach gut zum Tracken
und zum
Sensoren auswerten anzeigen.
Wie viel Power man in die Pedale
tritt,
Herzfrequenz,
Geländesteigung. Ja das kann das
iPhone alles gar nicht, weil das gar nicht die
Funkprotokolle kann für die ganzen
Peripherie.
Nein hab ich nicht.
Würde ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht scheren,
weil da sieht man ja wo ich wohne.
Genau.
Nein ich rasier mir nicht die Beine.
Auch wenn es dazu Untersuchungen gibt,
dass man tatsächlich da irgendwie 1-2
Watt sparen kann, theoretisch mach ich nicht.
Hast du eine schnelle Radsportbrille?
Hab ich, hab ich.
Ich fahr sogar seit ner Weile Klickpedale jetzt.
Für die richtige,
für den richtigen Professional Look.
Allerdings nicht die
nicht die Straßen
Variante, sondern die Mountainbike Variante.
Weil man damit
wenigstens noch ein paar Meter laufen kann.
Ist nicht down, du musst klicken?
Wo muss ich denn klicken?
Für mich sieht das
Für mich sieht das down aus.
Was machst du dann an Ampel,
wenn du eingeklickt bist?
Da hast du 2 Varianten. Entweder bist du
richtig Pro und kannst
so standen auf dem
Fahrrad, während du nicht
vorwärts fährst. Gibt Leute, die können das.
Kann ich aber nicht.
Ich klick einfach
auf der linken Seite aus und stell den Fuß runter.
Track Stand, genau.
Ich klick einfach aus und stell den Fuß runter.
Die Strava Kenner sind hier am Start.
Reboot, ne Schwachsinn.
Wir müssen nicht rebooten.
Ich kann doch, komm scheiß drauf,
ich reboote 300 Mal die VM.
Weil's geht.
Reboot.
Oh, Leute.
Moment, lasst mich noch kurz aufs Handy gucken.
Passives Einkommen gerade wieder angesagt.
Ich hab Rufbereitschaft heute Nacht.
Fast so gut wie Stonks.
Stonks gehen auch gut ab.
Aber fast so gut wie Stonks.
Ich mach nix, ich streame und
verdiene damit Geld.
Wie lange? Bis morgen um 7.30 Uhr.
Ich wollte irgendwas noch sagen.
Mit der Fahrradgeschichte angefangen.
Ich will nur ein Wera-Kit.
Was ihr euch
alles merkt, Alter.
Ja.
Aber nicht wieder
nen Torx-Schraubendreher-Kit.
Das hab ich jetzt ja schon.
Handy auf lautlos und dann erst mal
pennen. Ich hab das Handy auch während Rufbereitschaft
immer auf lautlos. Aber
ich hab die App, die Nachrichten
schickt, hab ich
auf Favorit. Das heißt, das geht durch
das Lautlose durch.
Und wenn einer anruft, dann hör ich das mit Vibrationsanzeigen.
Bei mir auf dem Nachttisch.
Ich hatte das am Anfang
immer laut. Und wenn dann was war,
manchmal chatten die Leute
auch irgendwann, keine Ahnung, um
halb drei oder
so im Teams. Und dann macht's
und ich denk mir, Alter, was denn jetzt los?
Fuck. Dann guck ich drauf,
dann schreibt dann irgendeiner nachts, wo er mal
aufs Klo gegangen ist oder so in den Chat,
ach ja übrigens,
morgen früh bitte dran denken, Service XY
durchzustarten. Alter, das ist halb drei.
Geht mir nicht auf den Sack.
Seitdem hab ich das immer lautlos.
Und die App, die
Alerts verschickt, ist als Favorit
drinne. Und
die klingelt eh. Und
Anrufe hör ich auch so.
Kette wachsen. Beste. Beste.
Müsste ich mal wieder. Müssen wir
wieder die Kette wachsen.
Bevor da jetzt irgendwie einer was
Perverses reininterpretiert, ich mein das
wörtlich. Muss
wirklich mal wieder die Kette am Fahrrad wachsen.
Habt ihr eine App für
Alarme?
Äh, so ein Ding, was sonst irgendwie
gefühlt nur drei Leute auf der Welt
verwenden, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob ich's jetzt sage. Ne, ich sag's
nicht. Wobei man's weiß,
wenn ich die Streams gezei- ich hab ja
da haben wir doch schon Sachen gestreamt, da hab ich
sogar was dafür programmiert, also
weiß man's eigentlich schon.
Was ich benutze, ich, wie gesagt,
das ist nix von mir, das ist was auf dem
Handy von der Firma
vorinstalliert ist. Ich hab zwei Handys, ein privates
und das von der Firma. Nach dem
ich beim letzten
Arbeitgeber nur ein Handy hatte und
quasi das Firmenhandy privat benutzt
hab, hab ich mir gedacht, ey, das machst du nicht mehr.
Machst du nicht nochmal.
Ich hab'n
privates Handy und das Firmenhandy kommt nur
das drauf.
Ich werd' müde, ey.
Bald bad getimed, Leute.
Auf dem Firmenhandy mach ich gar nix
custommäßiges, da lass ich mir alles vom MDM
drauf installieren und benutze nur das Nötigste.
Was man
zum Arbeiten braucht, den Rest mach ich auf meinem
privaten Handy. Ja. Ja.
Ich hab' da echt keinen Bock mehr.
Wie sollen das mit irgendwelchen komischen
MDM-Apps versauen? Ist mir egal,
das ist das Firmenhandy. Juckt mich nicht.
Ich kann jedes Mal sagen, wenn
irgendwas nicht geht, Jungs,
Handy geht nicht, guckt mal, please. Nicht
mein Problem. MDM ist
Mobile Device Management.
Das ist quasi
Softwareverteilung für Handys.
Da kannst du Apps drauf pushen und Settings
und VPNs einrichten und sowas.
Bring your own device.
Naja.
Je nachdem, was du auf deinem Handy
brauchst und VPN-Einwahl und sonst
was, ist es eigentlich selten
bring your own device, was das Handy angeht.
Du darfst höchstens das Firmenhandy
benutzen, auch privat.
Aber das will ich nicht mehr.
Das ist mir zu hakelig
und zu versaut mit
irgendwelchen komischen Apps und
irgendwelchen komischen Extradingern bei uns,
diese Handys.
Naja, also, ich benutze mein
eigenes Handy für mein privates
Zeug und das Firmenhandy ausschließlich
für Sachen
von der Arbeit.
Und da kann ich halt auch sagen, wenn da mal
irgendwie das VPN nicht geht, die Mails nicht gehen
oder so, sag ich, ey, Leute hier,
euer Handy tut nicht, guckt mal, please.
Und dann gucken die.
Das meiste ist eh durch den Reboot behoben.
3D-Druck, ich hab einen 3D-Drucker,
ja. Ich hab einen 3D-Drucker
und hab mich dementsprechend auch mit
3D-Druck beschäftigt, allerdings nicht
jetzt irgendwie super krass im Detail. Und ich mach
da auch nichts Großartiges. Also,
es ist nicht so, als drück ich mir jetzt irgendwie eigene Warhammer
Figuren aus und bemale die und sowas.
Wobei ich da echt sagen muss, ohne
Scheiß, das ist eigentlich
schon so ein bisschen was, wo ich mich
potenziell sehen würde. Ich mag Warhammer,
auch wenn ich's nicht spiele und
nicht
bring das immer durcheinander. Ist Game Workshop
das mit Warhammer? Ja.
Ähm, in den ich
unbedingt Geld in Rachen schmeißen will. Aber
ich mag Warhammer an sich, vom Setting her,
von der
von das, wie kann man das Story nennen?
Ja,
von der Atmosphäre, von der Welt,
von Worldbuilding heißt das, glaub ich.
Mag ich Warhammer.
Auch, äh,
ich guck mir auch gerne YouTube-Stories aus dem Warhammer
Universum an.
Und, wobei das hauptsächlich Warhammer
40k ist. Darf man
Warhammer-Figuren drucken? Das kann dir keiner
verbieten, was du auf deinem privaten Drucker
Ob du's streng legal darfst,
keine Ahnung, aber solange du's nicht vermarktest, seh ich da
überhaupt kein Problem. Dann würde ich mich
potenziell sehen, aber das ist mir zu aufwendig.
Es ist mir zu aufwendig, also
da brauchst du ja wirklich
das ist ja ne Wissenschaft für sich
detailreiche Sachen
zu drucken. Da musst du das richtige Material
vor allem erstmal finden, die richtigen Druck-Settings
dann muss das Ganze noch irgendwie danach
poliert oder mit Säure
irgendwie abgeätzt werden und dann
da würde ich mich potenziell sehen, aber
bin ich zu faul für.
Aber ich hab nen 3D-Drucker
und ich benutze
den auch ab und zu, aber meistens nicht
um irgendwas filigranes zu drucken,
sondern vielleicht ein Gehäuse für nen
Microcontroller oder sowas, ja.
Ich glaube das Praktischste
das Praktischste, was ich
was ich gedruckt hab bisher, war mal so
ein Filter für die Regenrinne.
Der alte ist kaputt gegangen, da hab ich 3D gedruckt, den neuen.
Wann wieder Videos?
Am Wochenende, ist die Standardantwort.
Ja, ich weiß, es wird echt mal wieder Zeit.
Es wird echt mal wieder Zeit.
Das ist nicht der erste.
Und nicht nur heute, sondern
es kommt jedem Stream mehrfach.
Der vergammelt im Serverraum.
Ja, so oft benutze ich meinen 3D-Drucker nicht.
Das stimmt, das habe ich sogar
versprochen, dass ich ein Video dazu mache.
Ob sich der Jobwechsel gelohnt hat oder nicht.
Sag das mal nicht zu laut,
das ist sicherlich der feuchte Traum
mancher
Verwertungs...
Darf man das nennen? Das heißt ja nicht so.
Mancher Hersteller. Das ist der feuchte Traum,
dass der 3D-Drucker
scannt demnächst. Also,
bei Druckern
selbst ist es ja zumindest schon so,
wenn du versuchst Geldscheine zu drucken.
Ich kann euch übrigens empfehlen,
das nicht auszuprobieren.
Und es ist auch nicht so,
dass sich das jetzt irgendwie falsch anhört.
Aber ich weiß,
dass das bei einigen Druckern nicht geht.
Wenn ihr versucht Geldscheine zu scannen
und zu drucken, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Manche Hersteller haben quasi
Detektorsachen drin im Drucker,
dass man keine Geldscheine
damit scannen und drucken kann.
Ja, ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Viele Anbieter lehnen mittlerweile
Custom Domains komplett ab.
Also, wenn du nicht gerade
bei gmail, gmx, web.de oder sonst was bist,
lehnen die einfach die E-Mail ab.
Selbst wenn es
eine legit gekaufte Domain mit einem
E-Mail-Postfach ist.
Das liegt nicht an Cloudflare, das liegt an den Anbietern,
die einfach gar keine Custom Domains mehr nehmen.
Haben wir nicht. Sollen wir vielleicht machen,
ist eine gute Idee.
Mein Lieblingsdialog in all den Jahren
war immer noch,
es kommt eine Mail an,
an das Admin-Postfach damals.
Das System geht
nicht mehr.
Und eigentlich war die bei uns
komplett falsch. Und das wusste ich auch,
dass die bei uns komplett falsch ist.
Aber ich dachte mir so, ey,
du hast zufälligerweise mal in das Admin-Postfach
geguckt. Keine Sau guckt jemals in das Admin-Postfach.
Bist du einfach mal nett und
antwortest sie und sagst, sie ist falsch bei dir.
Und da habe ich sie gefragt,
ja, um welches System geht's denn?
Ich leite das mal weiter, also sie sind da
komplett falsch gelandet, aber
ich leite es weiter.
Und da antwortet sie,
na das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Oder das System, mit dem ich täglich arbeite.
Da wusste ich natürlich sofort Bescheid,
welches System jetzt das richtige ist
zum Weiterleiten, ja.
Ich habe das dann weitergeleitet auf
gut Glück und die wussten auch gleich, was gemeint ist.
Witzigerweise. Anscheinend kennen die
die schon. Bei uns wurde gemeldet,
dass die Klimaanlage nicht funktioniert.
Naja, bei uns hat es mal gebrannt im Rechenzentrum.
Das Gegenteil
von Klimaanlage funktioniert nicht.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das wirklich
brennen nennen kann.
Sehr starke
Rauchentwicklung im Rechenzentrum.
Was ist eurer Meinung nach
die beste Jobbörse im Bereich
IT?
Ehrlich gesagt,
als erstes fällt mir StepStone ein von früher.
Die waren früher mit die größte,
was das angeht. Aktuell weiß ich's nicht.
Du kannst dir einfach,
mach dir einfach einen LinkedIn Account
und lass dich von
Azubis vollspammen.
Was sonst?
Ach so, du meinst
die Story mit dem Rechenzentrum
im Wohnzimmer.
Nein, das war das nicht.
In Frankfurt war das.
Nicht in Ulm.
Ja gut, das kannst du dir aber auch
nicht Schritt halten.
Woher solltest du das auch wissen, dass das unbenannt wurde?
In letzter Zeit sind super viele Recruiter
aus Indien auf LinkedIn mit deutschen Jobs
unterwegs.
Moment, die Recruiter kommen aus Indien,
aber die suchen deutsche für deutsche Jobs?
Wie kommt's
denn zu dieser Konstellation?
Get in IT.
Ist das nicht von irgendeinem deutschen
YouTube-Tuber
auch
diese Geschichte?
Das hab ich doch schon öfters mal gehört.
War das nicht Morpheus,
der Werbung dafür macht manchmal?
Ulm ist dir liebenswert.
Bestimmt nur wegen
Elo Tricks.
25 Zentimeter
oder so, warum was sonst?
Das kann natürlich sein.
Ich kenn die Seite nicht, ich hab die noch nie verwendet.
Wollen wir mal gucken hier.
In welcher Stadt?
Frankfurt.
Dein Berufsfeld.
Zeig mal hier, was haben wir denn da?
System Engineering Admin.
Oh ja.
Sieht jetzt ehrlich gesagt aus, wie halt so eine
115-Job-Börse so aussieht.
Vielleicht ein bisschen
übersichtlicher.
Responsive
Webdesign hier.
Das ist doch bestimmt
ein CSS-Grid.
Oh, nee.
Doch, doch, doch.
Hier.
Ich hätte jetzt erst gedacht,
das ist Tailwind,
aber
es ist nicht Tailwind.
Es ist Bootstrap?
Ist das Bootstrap, Leute?
Sieht ein bisschen nach Bootstrap aus.
Frankfurt erwähnt.
Frankfurt wird öfters mal
erwähnt.
Übrigens, muss ich jetzt mal was zeigen.
Passt mal auf.
Die Welt ist wirklich nicht mehr zu retten.
Ich kenn das nicht. Soll ich mal danach suchen?
Ist das?
Ein Fisch.
Endpoint-Management-Software.
Das hört sich eher an wie
Softwareverwaltung an.
Das hört sich eher nach Softwareverwaltung an.
Siggi, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog-Subscription.
Prime-Sub.
Pass mal auf, die Menschheit ist echt nicht mehr zu retten.
Ich hoffe,
Brücke-Rapper.
Ich hoffe, ich finde diese News jetzt.
Hier.
Die Polizei
hat zwei Leute festgenommen
auf einer Brücke,
auf einer Autobahnbrücke
oder auf einer Brücke, die über eine Straße ging,
weil sie dort
mit einem Schlagring und einer Armbrust
rumgefuchtelt haben.
Und am Ende kam raus,
die wollten nicht etwa auf Autos schießen
oder sowas, die haben ein Gangster-Rap-Video
gedreht.
Und damit sie mehr Gangster rüberkommen,
haben sie halt einen Schlagring
und eine Armbrust dabei gehabt.
Also am Montagabend den Dreh
eines Rap-Videos im Stadtteil
Bockenheim gestoppt, hatten Zeugen die Polizei
erinnert, dass sie eine größere Person im Bereich
der Brücke gesehen haben.
Da soll beobachtet worden sein, wie ein Mann
eine Waffe in die Luft gereckt haben soll.
Diese stellte sich später als Armbrust heraus.
Die Polizei rückte
mit einem großen Angebot auf.
Ja, zu viel Gangster-Rap
am Start gewesen.
Zu viele Gangster
auf kleinem Raum.
Frankfurt-Gürtelstraße,
Louis V. Torstor, zahl die Kollektion Bar,
fick auf Sponsor.
Einzige Sachen, die ich kenne in dem Zusammenhang.
Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt,
ich bin der große Haftbefehl-Kenner.
Das Einzige,
legit das Einzige, was ich kenne,
ist, dass ich nicht
über 3 Meter Kontrolle darf.
Gerade was Entwicklerrechner und sowas angeht.
Entwickler sind halt Leute,
die auch mal was ausprobieren müssen.
Wenn man da zu restriktiv ist, beschränkt man die Leute
einfach darin, sie können nicht mehr richtig arbeiten.
Wenn jetzt natürlich einer,
da hab ich ja auch schon
den Geisterserver, hab ich sogar mal
hab ich sogar mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Geisterserver.
Wenn einer irgendwas Produktionsreifes,
Wichtiges unterm Schreibtisch hat,
und wenn einer dagegen tritt,
ist das weg, ist natürlich kacke.
Der Polizeieinsatz, der kommt bestimmt
im Gangster-Video drin vor.
Ich würde auch macOS auf der Arbeit nehmen,
sofort, ohne Scheiß, würde ich sofort nehmen.
Wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
zwischen, sagen wir, einem Windows-Notebook
oder einem macOS-Notebook, ich würde sofort
einen macOS-Notebook nehmen. So instant
würde ich einen macOS-Notebook nehmen.
So schnell könntest du nicht gucken,
wie ich einen macOS-Notebook
nehmen würde.
Das liegt aber daran,
dass Windows halt einfach nur
kompletter Abfall mittlerweile ist.
Aber wirklich komplett unusable Crap.
Gerade Windows-Server.
Ich merk's ja gerade in der Schulung,
die ich da machen muss.
Da ist zum größten Teil fast alles Windows.
Und wie gesagt, ich mach die Schulung nur,
damit wir die Lizenzbedingungen
des Herstellers erfüllen.
Nicht weil ich da irgendwie,
weil man da groß was lernt.
Nee, hab ich noch nicht.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit Recall in der EU aus?
Ist es da wenigstens standardmäßig ausgeschaltet?
Ja, ihr könnt mich Sachen zu Windows fragen.
Ihr könnt mich auch genauso gut Sachen
zu C++ fragen oder sowas.
Mit dem Unterschied ist,
dass ich von C++ zumindest noch ein bisschen Ahnung
habe, wenn es allerdings...
Problem ist, wenn ihr mir C++-Fragen
stellt, ist, es kann durchaus
sein, dass ich es euch beantworten kann.
Aber ihr müsst dann damit leben,
dass ich neben der Frage 30 Minuten
mich noch über C++ aufrege.
Und zu Windows kann ich gar nichts sagen,
weil ich davon überhaupt keine Ahnung hab.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ich will davon auch keine Ahnung haben
und ich mach da soweit auch einen Bogen drum,
dass ich davon nie Ahnung haben werde.
Das glaub ich nicht,
dass da irgendwas besser wird.
Einen Window Manager hab ich auch gehört,
manche Leute verwenden unter macOS so Zusatzkrempel.
Am liebsten würde ich hier einfach
einen Linux-Notebook mit Arch-Linux verwenden.
By the way.
Äh...
Gibt's da was Neues?
Da gab's doch vor...
drei Wochen oder so gab's doch schon mal da irgendwas.
Äh...
Ich hab auch keinen.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile
ein ESP-Board
mit der neuen China-CPU.
Hab ich aber noch nicht.
Alles Schrott.
Ich hab doch letztens sogar mal Tidingsachen für Windows ausprobiert.
Das war alles eklig.
Hast du nicht den Game Freak League mitbekommen?
Anscheinend nicht.
Also das sind die Pokémon-Leute.
Oder?
Hab ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Ah hier Pokémon-Zeug.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ja, juckt mich ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht,
was Nintendo da so treibt.
Ich warte, bis die nächste Konsole am Start ist.
Google oder Django für einfache Webseiten.
Wie wär's mit
statischem HTML-CSS
für einfache Webseiten?
Ohne irgendwas?
Ja.
Ich weiß, das generiert das am Ende auch.
Aber wozu?
Wenn's einfach nur drei Seiten sind, warum nicht einfach ganz normales
statisches HTML?
Du hast Admin-Rechte bekommen. Was du machen sollst?
Art-Schildungs installieren.
By the way, was sonst?
Fireship.
Okay, wir gucken.
Wir checken Fireship-Video ab.
Das League.
Okay.
Ach doch!
Jetzt weiß ich, um was es geht.
Natürlich hab ich das mitgekriegt.
Ich hab's mir aber noch nie im Detail angeguckt hier.
Ich find übrigens die Aussprache von den Amis immer geil.
Pokémon.
4chan ist die family-friendlieste Seite,
die es gibt.
Und auch ihre Lieblings-Pokémon Typhlosion wurde gegründet.
Ich hatte keine sexuelle Beziehung zu diesem Pokémon.
Er lüftet, aber mehr darauf später.
Der mysteriöse Hacker hinter dem Freak-Leak ist nicht für Blut.
Und er scheint ein Fan zu sein, der ein paar Daten zurückhält, um Spoiler zu vermeiden.
und er scheint ein Fan zu halten, der ein paar Daten zurückhält, um Spoiler zu vermeiden.
Aber das Interessanteste ist, dass dieser Leak
ein bisschen Licht aufweist, weshalb Nintendos Legal-Team
die Open-Source-Switch-Emulatoren
Ja, ja, ja, sie sind alle weg.
Man denkt, die Blut-Leihe ist ein Weisheit,
aber das ist ein komischer Teil.
Es ist der 22. Oktober, und das sind die Code-Reporte.
Game Freak wurde vor einem Jahr gehaxt,
und wir haben das erst 1 Woche vor Oktober 2013 herausgefunden.
Es ist eine japanische Firma,
und wie wir sehen, haben sie einen Freak in Game Freak.
Bevor wir freaky werden,
werden wir uns den Datenchef befassen.
Es klingt so, als ob jemand auf der DevOps-Team
ein Chomag777 auf ihrem GitLab-Server-Config-File mit
der Beleuchtung für einen Admin-User auf der Webseite anmachte.
Wenn du dich mit dem Chomag777 nicht kennst,
anyone to read, write and execute.
Ja, aber, aber, aber
du brauchst erstmal Zugriff auf den Server.
... to file. It wasn't some crazy
quantum computing attack by the Russians.
Oder war das dann auch
public über Web-Server irgendwie
zugreifbar oder so?
Nur weil eine Datei irgendwo auf dem Server liegt
und 777 hat, passiert ja erstmal noch nichts.
It was just some Pokemon-Fan snooping around
who got lucky. And the rest is history.
Ah, das muss ich mal kurz lesen.
GitLab-Server-Configuration für... Aha!
Lucky. And the rest is history.
Game Freak issued an apology and will never
let this happen again in the future, because as
you can see here, it exposed all kinds of
proprietary code and never-before-seen
assets that we'll take a look at now.
Indeed, I did have a relationship...
Hab ich, hab ich, hab ich, ähm...
... mir noch...
... nice. Alte SVN-Stills.
Indeed, I did
have a relationship... ... with that Pokemon.
One of the biggest reveals in this leak is the
Codename for the Nintendo Switch 2.
Outs. Back in January, the betting
odds to see a Nintendo Switch released in
2024 were about 90%.
But now the odds are all the way down to 20%.
In any case, the leak confirms that they are working
on a Pokemon game for the Nintendo Switch 2,
which is now believed to be named Gaia,
with the main theme being island
exploring in an archipelago. What's most interesting
though, is that there's an alleged spec for...
Ist aber wieder was
ganz was Neues.
... for the Nintendo Switch 2. That mentions
12 GB of RAM, where the original
Switch had 4 GB, and 256
GB of internal storage,
compared to 32 on the... Ja gut, ganz
ehrlich, ich kann bis heute nicht verstehen,
wie das überhaupt
möglich ist, dass die Leute mit 32 GB
Storage bei der Switch ausgekommen
sind. The original Switch
and will be powered by an NVIDIA... Gut, es gab
nicht viele Games, aber trotzdem!
... the Tegra Processor, with people
estimating a minimum price... Ich mein, es gibt
Leute, die sind so verrückt, die haben sogar Witcher 3
gespielt auf der Switch. Keck, wait,
Alter, das ist doch ziemlich die schlechteste Plattform, wo man das Game
drauf spielen kann. ... of $399.
Uh, wait a second,
this just in, we've got some breaking news.
It looks like another leak has just hit Nintendo,
because yesterday on October 21st
a bunch of details about its private
online playtest began appearing online.
This time it doesn't appear to be hackers, but
rather participants breaking their NDAs.
It looks like they're building some kind of sandbox
MMO, like Minecraft or Roblox,
or possibly just stress-testing their
multiplayer infrastructure. Moment, es gibt Apex
auf der Switch? Das wusste ich gar nicht.
But Nintendo is DMCA-striking
anyone that posts it online. So let's
get back to our Game Freak leak, because one of the most
revealing things is that it appears that
the Switch 2 could have the same ROM-Format
as Switch 1. And that would explain why Nintendo
has been waging a ruthless war against
Nintendo. Das macht auch durchaus Sinn,
wenn das quasi
mehr oder weniger, sagen wir mal,
ein Upgrade der bestehenden
Infrastruktur ist.
Das Ding basiert ja auf
irgendeiner Version von
Nvidia, Tegra, sonst was,
von der es wahrscheinlich mittlerweile
auch schon neuere Versionen und schnellere Versionen
gibt, oder zumindest
Nvidia da mit Nintendo irgendwas kochen
kann, ja. Und
man darf nicht vergessen,
dass die, der
Gamecube, die
Wii und die Wii U im Prinzip,
jetzt mal übertrieben gesagt, von der Architektur
her, auch mehr oder weniger die gleiche
Konsole war, nur schneller.
Stimmt nicht ganz,
ja. Aber Nintendo wird
da auch nicht jetzt komplett das Rad
neu erfinden. Also das wäre schon
durchaus denkbar.
Ja, der andere
Entwickler, Hauptentwickler von diesem
anderen Emulator, da hat er angeblich ein Angebot
von Nintendo bekommen, was er nicht ablehnen
konnte. Klingt ja so ein bisschen Mafia-mäßig, ne?
A lawsuit that not only
took Yuzu offline, but they also agreed
to pay Nintendo 2.4 million dollars.
Then the only Switch emulator left
standing, Ryu Jinx, was contacted
by Nintendo on September 30th, where
they politely asked them to destroy their entire
project, to which they agreed, because they don't
want to feel the wrath of Nintendo's
legal team. The lead developer is based
in emulation-friendly Brazil, and there is
no lawsuit or DMCA takedown, but
the threat of a lawsuit is certainly implied.
And apparently, da gibt es doch wahrscheinlich schon
die ersten Forks, die am Start sind, oder?
They were close to making an iOS and Android port,
meaning Switch games could be played on tablets
and phones, and that's a terrifying loss of revenue
that Nintendo could just not allow to happen.
Especially with Apple and Google's App Store
monopolies being broken up, allowing
users to install third-party apps outside
the App Stores. Now, 99.9%
of people out there don't emulate or pirate
games, but for the average Pokémon
fan, this leak was a goldmine of unreleased
content. There's details and images
about scrapped content from past games,
details about new games in development,
and details about upcoming film and TV
projects, but I don't want to provide any
spoilers. All this stuff is easily searchable
on the internet now, but there is one piece
of unreleased lore that you need to know about,
about the backstory of classic Pokémon
Typhlosion. Many moons ago, the game was made by a
CEO, when the lines between Pokémon
and humans were still blurred,
Typhlosion disguised itself as a handsome
Giga-Chad, deceiving a young girl into
believing he was a suitable mate. The two
formed a relationship, and one thing led to
another, resulting in the girl giving birth
to a half-human, half-Pokémon
Pokémon child.
She was understandably freaked out, but Typhlosion
was not too chill about it, and threatened
to kill her dad if she told him the truth. Then,
the half-human, half-Pokémon hybrid died,
and they all lived happily ever after.
This has been the Code Report. Thanks for watching.
I will see you in the next one.
Outro